remember boosted boards they were a
premium electric skateboard company that
was quite popular back in their early
2010s largely thanks to one influencer
Casey neistat Casey was an avid user of
boosted boards and used them to get all
around New York City and given that he
was vlogging on a daily basis during
this time period and getting millions of
views on each and every video the amount
of brand exposure he got for boosted was
insane all of a sudden boosted was the
goto electric skateboard manufacturer
for millennials despite often costing
over ,000 per board pretty soon boosted
started receiving even more coverage
from Marcus brownley a few viral videos
and even traditional news outlets for
the longest time it seemed that boosted
was truly a humble Grassroots success
story that fulfilled a specific Niche
but things didn't stay that way forever
moving into the late 2010s we started
seeing viral stories pop up that boosted
boards were overheating and catching on
fire boosted didn't just try to sweep is
under the rug either they publicly
admitted the issue and announced a
recall of second generation boards
during the holiday season of 2016 making
it clear that they prioritized consumer
safety over maximizing profits but
despite their Goodwill they slowly faded
into the background as they resolved
their issues and came out with a new
generation of boards just like before
these boards were also covered by Casey
and a slew of other popular creators but
despite the social media coverage sales
didn't get all that much better for
boosted they even tried to diversify
their business but all of their efforts
to expand outside of Just skateboards
also fell flat and as a money burning VC
backed startup the only way that boosted
was going to survive was by showing
growth and given that they didn't have
much growth to show investors would
eventually pull the plug on boosted and
boosted would file for bankruptcy in mid
2020 looking back it seems that just one
public misstep destroyed the entire
company
but really the boards catching on fire
was just the tip of the iceberg so
here's what really happened to boost
it taking a look back the story of
boosted dates back to 2011 to a couple
of Stanford students named sanj dusto
John man and Matthew Tran like most
college students and urban dwellers in
general a daily pain point for these
guys was walking around campus and
nearby areas technically everything was
super close within just a few mile
radius but when you're constantly
walking back and forth between your
apartment classes grocery stores and
libraries commuting time starts to add
up pretty quickly the go-to solution for
most people is to Simply ride a bike but
arria wanted a smaller simpler solution
that could be easily carried around
without compromising on speed thus the
idea for an electric skateboard was born
and R Trio was by no means interested in
slapping a motor onto a skateboard and
calling it a day they wanted to create
an extremely refined and reliable
experience so they started designing a
motorized skateboard from scratch
constantly tweaking and improving each
aspect whether that be acceleration
breaking handling or durability
fortunately they had plenty of time and
resources to do this as they had secured
backing from Stanford's own startup
accelerator startx eventually they would
come up with the extremely premium board
that people would call the Apple of
eboards and to gauge just how interested
people would be about a boosted board
the trio would launch a Kickstarter
campaign with a goal of raising $100,000
to their surprise they would hit the
goal in just one day and they would end
up raising nearly half a million dollars
by all accounts this was a great success
but reading between the lines you could
already see a few red flags primarily
the number of backers despite raising
$467,000 boosted only had a total of
1100 backers the average backer was
putting up
$420 meaning that to reach their
$100,000 goal they only had to get 200
to 250 backers not a bad goal by any
means but really brings into question
just how big the target market really
was nonetheless boosted would continue
with their marketing and go to market
effort these were young guys who
understood the power of social media and
as such much of their efforts went into
growing their Reddit and Facebook pages
Sanjay even hosted a TED Talk that would
go viral pulling in nearly 2 million
views all of this traction helped
boosted raise another $10 million in
funding but what happened next was
something that none of them could have
ever anticipated boosted had caught the
attention of upand cominging YouTube
star Casey neistat who would
single-handedly boost interest in
boosted by a whopping
300% this trend would simply go into
overdrive when a Creator named Jesse
posted a viral video of in riding a
boosted board around New York City that
was made to look like the magic carpet
from Aladdin this video would go on to
reach 35 million views and Jesse would
go on to make a follow-up to this video
in San Francisco that went on to get 13
million views and all of that was just
on Jesse's Channel itself it's very
likely that with all of the reposts and
media coverage this little stunt drew
the attention of over 100 million people
boosted could not have even dreamed of a
more successful brand awareness campaign
but boo boed would soon learned that
brand awareness and sales were two
completely different
things none of this is to say that
boosted didn't have a roaring start just
due to the raw magnitude of exposure
that they enjoyed it they obviously sold
a bunch of boards though we don't know
the exact number but once all of the
hype settled down boosted was left with
a much trickier situation the reality
was that the original problem that they
were trying to solve did not even
benefit from their invention here's the
thing commuting on college campuses is
surely a hurdle for college students but
you know what's an even bigger hurdle
spending $400 to $500 or even over
$1,000 on a skateboard so aside from a
few Rich Kids boosted had largely boxed
themselves out of the college Market
simply due to price and this is really
quite a shame given that most college
students probably did know about boosted
and many of them probably even wanted
one but the price was simply too big to
swallow fortunately boosted also
appealed to Urban dwellers as well but
the same issue largely applied here
those who walked everywhere usually
couldn't not afford a premium electric
skateboard especially with the rents and
general cost of living in these cities
and those who could afford it weren't
exactly the kind to be riding around the
city I mean could you imagine an
investment banker or corporate lawyer
writing one of these to work on a
regular basis so really boosted boards
only appeal to exception cases like
Casey High income earners who regularly
Traverse the city this isn't to say that
YouTubers like Casey and Demarcus were
capping and that booster boards weren't
a great products they were phenomenal
products but just because you have a
phenomenal product doesn't mean that
it'll sell it's the same issue that
lucid is facing right now by all
accounts they've made a car that tops
not just Tesla but the EV industry in
general virtually every category a lot
of people would loved to have a lucid
but with that being said there's just
not all that many people who can buy a
$100,000 luxury electric sedan it was
the same thing with boosted and things
only got worse as competitors started
catching wind of this trend particularly
lime if you're not familiar with lime
scooter they're the guys who started the
whole electric scooter Trend basically
they were looking to do the exact same
thing as boosted but with two key
differences instead instead of
skateboards it was scooters which is a
lot easier to ride for most people and
two instead of having consumers buy
their scooters they had people rent
their scooters generally a lime scooter
costs a do to $150 to start riding and
then 15 to 39 cents per minute of riding
depending on the city from the business
side of things this was a terrible idea
because achieving profitability with
this model was a nightmare in fact a
major competitor at lime called bird
just filed for bankruptcy last month
after not being able to make this model
work but from the consumer side of
things this model was great they could
pay just a few bucks to get around the
city on a few occasions when they were
in a rush or were just feeling lazy
which was a lot more affordable than
getting a boosted board now you could
argue that these small transactions
eventually add up to being even more
than the price of a boosted board and
you're probably right but for most
consumers it's much easier to afford a
$5
upfront cost and just as boosted was
struggling to find their core market and
lined the scene boosted boards would
start catching
fire the whole Fiasco with boosted
boards Catching Fire takes us back to
late 2016 to a web developer named Rick
BRZ or more specifically his roommate
one day when Rick was out his boosted
board would start overheating and fill
his apartment with a bunch of toxic
smoke which naturally frightened his
roommate instead of vacating the
apartment as soon as possible though the
roommate would decide to record the
incident which as you would guess would
end up going viral on Reddit given that
boosted would eventually go bankrupt it
wouldn't have been surprising if boosted
had just pushed this under the rug and
acted like it never happened but boosted
did the exact opposite they did the
right thing they reached out to Rick
immediately offer further replacement
and wanted to take a look at the
defective board to fix the issue boosted
CEO sanj took it even one step further
he would fly from California to New York
just to meet up with Rick in person and
address the issue before they could
resolve the issue though another report
about a defective booster board would
come out and this would pretty much
force booster to issue a full recall it
turned out that the issue was that water
was able to get into the battery pack
when riding which eventually caused a
short circuit boosted would of course
fix the issue and come out with the
refined version but things were never
the same as such many Publications often
point to the fire incident as being the
definitive end to boosted but I argue
that they were already headed in that
direction and the fire incident simply
accelerated that Trend you see for sanj
electric skateboards was always just an
entry point into the Electric market his
end goal was always to build out a whole
slew of electric products like bikes and
scooters ERS but to his disappointment
these products never took off Sanjay was
even willing to step to the side and let
another person have a shot of being CEO
and expanding boosted but this wasn't
all that successful either well actually
technically they did continue to run
super successful marketing campaigns
they partnered with skateboarding legend
Tony Hawk and even almost Kanye West but
see brand awareness and marketing was
never where boosted fell short in the
first place they always crushed it in
those aspects
where they truly fell short was product
Market fit and profitability which
remained constant throughout their run
and eventually in mid 2020 they simply
ran out of funding and had no choice but
to file for bankruptcy they would sell
off the remaining parts of the business
to lime and a company who wanted to take
on the boosted brand name and if you
look at boosted today these new owners
are who show up but these guys have
nothing to do with the original boosted
other than the name and that's what
happened happened to boosted boards
another product that blew up in the
2010s only to fade into Oblivion was
GoPro check out this video to learn more
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one